How are you doing?
Someone is asking me,
you said some place that you felt like
you were at times dancing on broken
glass.
No,
I think I said that I was,
I always felt like I was
dancing on broken glass.
Are you getting enough rest and R.
And R is the food sensitivity
getting worked out?
I think maybe the food sensitivity
thing is getting worked out.
I think it's at the basis
of this depression that's
been played in my family for
generations,
but I haven't figured
out exactly what it is.
Yeah.
Town.
I'm working very hard on that with my
daughter who also seems to have the same
problem and it,
it is absolutely brutal.
It's absolutely brutal.
So,
um,
am I getting enough rest?
And R.
And R,
that's hard to say because with the
responses that I'd been having that have
knocked my health back,
it's,
it's hard to discriminate
between rest and our and our,
the lack of that and
just getting walloped by,
by eating what appears
to be the wrong thing.
So it's so funny because,
you know,
for years I was very skeptical of
anyone who was concerned about,
you know,
gluten sensitivity and that sort of thing.
But I sure learned that that was,
um,
arrogant.
So,
yeah.
Well,
I've found many times in my life that
you have to be aware of what you are
judgmental about because many
things come back to haunt you.